the distribution of average wait times
in drive-thru restaurant lines in one
town was approximately normal with mean
of 185 seconds and standard deviation of
11 seconds
amelia only likes to use the
drive-through for restaurants where the
average wait time is in the bottom 10
for that town
what is the maximum average wait time
for restaurants where emilia likes to
use the drive-thru
round to the nearest whole second like
always if you feel like you can tackle
this pause this video and try to do so
i'm assuming you paused it now let's
work through this together so let's
think about what's going on they're
telling us that the distribution of
average wait times is approximately
normal so let's get a visualization of a
normal distribution and they tell us
several things about this normal
distribution they tell us that the mean
is
185 seconds so that's 185 there the
standard deviation is 11 seconds so for
example this is going to be
11 more than the mean so this would be
196 seconds this would be another 11
each of these dotted lines or one
standard deviation more so this would be
207 this would be 11 seconds less than
the mean so this would be 174
and so on and so forth
and we want to find the maximum average
wait time for restaurants where amelia
likes to use the drive-through well what
are those restaurants that's where the
average wait time is in the bottom 10
for that town so how do we think about
it well there's going to be some value
let me mark it off right over here in
this red color
so we're going to have some threshold
value
right over here where
this is anything
that level or lower is going to be in
the bottom 10
well another way to think about it is
this is the largest wait time for which
you are still in the bottom 10
and so this area right over here is
going to be 10 of the total or it's
going to be 0.10
so the way we can tackle this is we can
get up a z table and figure out what
z-score gives us a proportion of only
0.10
being less than that z-score
and then using that z-score we can
figure out this value the actual wait
time so let's get our z table out and
since we know that this is below the
mean the mean would be the 50th
percentile we know we're going to have a
negative z-score so i'm going to take
out the part of the table that has the
negative z-scores on
it and remember we're looking for 10
percent
but we don't want to go beyond 10
percent we want to be sure that that
value is within the 10th percentile that
any higher will be out of the 10th
percentile
so let's see when we have these really
negative z's so far it only gets it only
doesn't even get to the first percentile
yet so let's scroll down a little bit
and let's remember as we do so that this
is 0 in the hundredths place 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9. so let's remember those columns
so let's see if we are at a z score of
negative
1.28 remember this is the hundreds is
zero one two three four five six seven
eight so this right over here is a z
score of negative one point two eight
and that's a little bit crossing the
10th percentile
but if we get a little bit more negative
than that we are in the 10th percentile
so this is negative
1.29 and this does seem to be the
highest z-score for which we are within
the 10th percentile
so negative
1.29 is our z-score
so this is z
equals negative 1.29 and if we want to
figure out the actual value for that we
would start with the mean which is 185
and then we would say well we want to go
1.29 standard deviations below the mean
the negative says we're going below the
mean so we could say
minus
1.29 times the standard deviation
and they tell us up here the standard
deviation is 11 seconds
so it's going to be 1.29
times 11
and this is going to be equal to
1.29
times 11
is equal to 14.19
and then i'll make that negative and
then add that to 185 plus 185
is equal to 170.81
170.81
now they say round to the nearest whole
second there's a couple of ways to think
about it if you really want to ensure
that you're not going to cross the 10th
percentile you might want to round to
the nearest second that is below this
threshold so you might say that this is
approximately
170 seconds if you were to just round
normally this would go to 171 but just
by doing that you might have crossed the
threshold but in all likelihood for this
application where someone is concerned
about wait time at drive-thru
restaurants that difference in a second
between 170 and 171 is not going to be
mission critical so to speak but you
could say safely said 170 or 171 seconds
will meet amelia's needs